alors choisi de montrer des looks olive
et tu vas me dire si un gardien ou pas
on a saisi la cei on regarde céline dion
qui a dormi apparemment chine valérie
damidot aime bien ça ou pas à chaud
c'est super cool
ouais c'est un débat aussi je trouve et
célina peut tout se permettre ouais mais
ça j'adore mais la soudure que c'est pas
mal non pour aller ouvrir des huîtres
mapa mode ne te parle pas c'est une joie
le met ses frais watine mes frères on
croit que tu vas te refaire le bâtiment
quelqu'un d'autre regardez rihanna oui
c'est beau très beau ça mohamed saleck
l'habiller rihanna oui je l'habille
souvent ce que je sais qu'il est un peu
sur mes côtes
mon lot l'asticot a toujours regarde sac
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire faute et ta cravate
ul-haq du à découper d'un ton pantalon
si la montée jusqu ici
à l'époque j'étais top model c'était un
garçon tombe
c'était pour une association caritative
ah ouais bon et honnête et fidèle
cliente à la cravate frère avec la
donnée ou quoi même pas il est caché ça
mais on faire l'ensemble dès que je les
appelle sont marocaines c'est paco
rabanne
[Rires]
à les regarder
c'est madonna quand elle était aux
buffalos des mois mais vous savez que ça
c'est un délire aussi et tu arrives à
reconnaître le couturier par exemple la
non non je pense que je suis pas sûr
qu'il y en ait un alors non ça c'est pas
un couturier sa fille qui passait sa
lâcheté ça dans une secte sérail et
enfin le dernier perdait le dernier
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]